John we had this question come in from
Christopher león and his Twitter handle
is at Chris underscore Langan and he
writes hi I would love to hear something
about a cliffhanger what should be
considered and written in the script
coupe anger is a very important
technique in television and cliffhanger
is simply a moment in this story when
the hero is in maximum danger but
instead of playing out that event to its
conclusion we stop it right before it
gets resolved typically with the hero at
their weakest point they are hanging
from a cliff right and so why would we
have a cliffhanger what's the value of
stopping that scene right there and
going to a different storyline the idea
is we're trying to hold the audience so
that we can get them to come back this
is why we often get cliff hangers in
television right before a commercial
because we'll want to try to hold on to
them so they don't go to another show
using the remote control now the way is
written into the script you don't of
course say well this is a cliffhanger
you don't need to write anything
differently to say that it's a
cliffhanger
it is a cliffhanger by virtue of what
happens in the action so the real trick
here is not how do you write it in the
script
the real trick is how do you set it up
in the story and to do that what you
have to do is have at least one other
major action line that you can cut to
you cannot have a cliffhanger if you
have a single story line so where you'd
get it is in a show with multiple
storylines that are unfolding
simultaneously and then at the crucial
moment you stop one story line jump over
to the next storyline then you take that
to a cliffhanger jump back to the first
line resolved
cliffhanger there and take them to the
next step
you